what happened with uh old teddy
spaghetti
uh teddy spaghetti uh still getting a
little messed with
a little bit by some folks uh missing
link's been out there messing missy
links my hero with this stuff so we
asked him about this uh
to follow up and give us more details
about this wheelchair guy that he had uh
doxxed
okay so the the super chat the missing
link sent
was did you really swat a disabled kid
who trolled you
did you really swat a disabled kid who
trolled you i didn't swat
anyone i contacted
the first of all he wasn't a kid he was
an adult
but yes i did actually contact both his
employer
and i also contacted
his local police and
they actually went out to his house once
and then the second time
brought him into the station he was
making threats
he was engaged in an ongoing period of
cyber harassment
okay first off i don't believe he was
making threats i i don't believe no
that's what people always lie
and right secondly you [ __ ] [ __ ]
you dark eel you can [ __ ] master
karate fighter
what was this kid gonna go from
massachusetts to italy to beat you up
hey
dude relax you're talking to the [ __ ]
dark lord though yeah am i the
dark lord you understand he'll tell on
you [ __ ] you teddy spaghetti
[ __ ] dude he will tell on you stop i
don't want to go yes [ __ ] [ __ ] you
[ __ ] [ __ ]
and he was also um
planting some extremely
questionable materials let's say
underage related materials
on public forums under other people's
names
he was also harassing uh a married
couple
the he was harassing the female half
of a married couple who lost a child
hey vox first of all stop pretending
like you're not
like you're above harassing married
people whose kids just died
like let's stop pretending like i love
people that have moral justifications
for things but you're not a moral person
you said yourself you're okay with
doxing people you did
you're okay with ruining the lives of
people who stand in contrast to what you
believe in
so um you can't then moral
about well he was messing with some
guy's wife and their kid just died
you wouldn't care vox yeah you don't
care know those people so shut up
um i have no sympathy
whatsoever for anyone who does that you
got that wrong
you have no empathy whatsoever i think
is the problem with you in general for
anyone but yours and by the way
a lot of the stuff you're describing
this guy was doing
in terms of harassing people and all
that stuff you owen benjamin does that
[ __ ] all the time and you're starting a
company with him
i've heard him go after people call them
snakes he said steven spielberg's
definitely a
no no what are some what are what are
some of the claims that owens made no
no no no i'd like to correct you there
it wasn't that steven spielberg molested
a kid
it was my own benjamin said and i quote
steven spielberg literally a child to
i remember that quote because i remember
it was like
what yeah yeah he said that i'm just
trying to murder
his family yes also that so
what are you talking about teddy
spaghetti
um you know the
he's wearing a shirt that says alt hero
yeah it was his comic thing
was it yeah wow that's really cool made
my position perfectly clear
you know if you engage if you cross
any legal lines we'll know
and we'll act they're gonna act bro they
are
you know what they mean by that right
what do they mean by that they're gonna
tell on you
oh no he's going to tattletail
keep [ __ ] with me pal i'll act oh no
teddy i'll call your job daddy spaghetti
i'm going to call your
job and say that you said mean words on
the internet big old tuffy tedward
spaghett word and so
um teddy's a tough guy that's not sweet
yeah
he's al dente he's a tough guy over here
spotting
that's just filing a criminal complaint
like like a so
uh if you don't do anything criminal
then there isn't any any need to worry
about that but
yes but when you brought this up last
time
you used that as a threat to us who have
done nothing criminal
who said i've actually had someone
dragged out of their groups now he's the
story's different
i had a kid dragged out of his grandma's
house and he was in a wheelchair
and you use it as some sort of throw the
understanding there's we haven't done
anything illegal teddy spaghetti
so uh why don't you shut up you [ __ ]
loser
and by the way teddy spaghetti
unauthorized still
[ __ ] sucks and i wouldn't be part of
it it was the last website on the planet
you know
the thing is most people have no idea
what the laws in their area are but he
does
he's not he knows the love you're no
expert in the law yeah teddy you look
like a guy who knows all the age of
consent laws in every state he is the
law yeah he is
yeah he is and so
uh you know sometimes people do things i
mean keep in mind
there's sometimes people do things we go
we check it out and we realized that how
is your mouth always so wet
he's yeah it really is he has such a wet
mouth
self-lubricating mouth yes seriously
you know they haven't crossed a line
so there's nothing to do but
uh every jurisdiction has different
cyber stalking
and different cyber harassment and
harassment staff
being a grown man and explaining all of
this to people yeah i know
it's it really is i'll call your job and
i'll get the cops on you because you
shouldn't mean words to me on the
internet
because i'm the dark lord are you the
dark lord you're a [ __ ]
dork dark snitch we've embarrassed you
in a way that you'll never recover from
uh and so and legally by the way um
you know you just have to figure out
figure what outbox where they are
okay and what the relevant law is
and if they cross the line then they've
just
handed you something to you know you
they've just handed you a weapon
if they don't cross line they don't but
but yeah i mean i i don't i don't
tell people these things
i wouldn't say things like that if they
weren't true
so then he goes on
to this uh
possible lawsuit against owen let's see
what he says
any word on owen opening himself up to a
lawsuit
um yes i'm
i think that's laughable because um
anyone who thinks that anybody is going
to be doing any lawsuits
over anything uh
is clearly doesn't know much about how
the law works or how expensive it is
oh no no no no no no no no
no i don't think you understand
daddy's spaghetti mister how the law
works
i sure those are the things that you're
telling owen because he's calling you
and
panicking panicking panicking panicking
as he should be wasn't he the guy who
sued a bunch of people
didn't he wasn't he the guy that sued
people uh that he tried to go after
4chan
teddy spaghetti you're lying to owen
because owen is scared now
teddy and you're his little daddy figure
we have to look good but look
you know what oh you know what teddy why
don't we look at what you said in the
last video
let's see what the applicable laws are
yeah
in that area yeah let's see uh sure the
state of washington
has applicable laws pretty good teddy
spaghetti accusing me of trying to
murder somebody's family
i'm sure that those those things are
something they take
seriously right he sued gab
um he sued gab he sued
gab he sued gab because they were making
fun of his wife i think
yeah well so what man no one's fault you
like stupid
first of all when you say owen opening
himself up to a lawsuit
anyone can sue anyone at any time
we know which made your lawsuit against
gab very frivolous
but see anyone can sue anyone for any
time
but once a lawsuit is done then you now
need to get a lawyer and pay money even
if you don't win
you got to get a lawyer you got to pay
money you got to pay money to defend
yourself
but you know that right because you know
all the laws
i can sue you you consume me um
we can all sue owen together
but turn your phone off i'm doing a
broadcast there is a massive massive
difference and keep in mind
i'm actively engaged in a very serious
legal dispute
right now you know and so
um the only people who flap their lips
about suing people are people who know
nothing about it
and have no intention or ability to do
so
but you're the one who said you were
going to sue
gab oh okay vox is a tough guy no no no
but this is what i'm asking is he is he
wants to do you want to bluff the is he
does he think that bluffing is happening
i don't think you understand teddy
spaghetti
it has become an obsession now to prove
how [ __ ] phony you are and then owen
going out on his broadcast to 250 000
subscribers
and saying that merch is trying to kill
my family
that's not something you can just say
without impunity right right
guess what gammas could get lawyers too
you [ __ ] idiot
gammas can get lawyers too i hate teddy
spaghetti it's a [ __ ] he's the
worst very hateable he is the [ __ ]
worst
the most hateable uh have you seen this
commercial
that three doll made the big bear debit
card
it is really well done and
professionally put together watch
legend logos logos logos
big bear bank introducing the big bear
debit card
holy [ __ ] this is amazing this card is
logos gary
free me from the shackles of google
[Music]
send super chats with one fingerprint
scan
[Music]
or just buy me [ __ ] at the store
put your cash directly in my wallet
buy my food and become a legend this is
[ __ ] amazing
no one is having
this is so goddamn childish
[Music]
developed by teddy spaghetti [ __ ]
legend
this is so good free room whack
with every 275 subscription room whack
i don't think he's going to appreciate
this
just legend logos logos